On me demande souvent
vous savez, qu'est-ce qui vous étonne à propos du livre?
Je réponds, que je l'aies écrit.
Jamais je n'aurais imaginé cela,
ni même dans mes rêves les plus fous --
je ne me considère même pas comme un auteur.
et on me demande souvent,
pourquoi pensez-vous que tant de personnes l'ont lu?
Ce bouquin se vend toujours à environ un million de copies par mois.
Et je pense que cela s'explique par le fait que le vide spirituel
est une maladie universelle.
Je pense que intérieurement à un moment donné, on couche notre tête sur l'oreiller et on se dit
"La vie, c'est forcément plus que ça."
Se lever le matin, aller au boulot, revenir à la maison et regarder la télé,
aller se coucher, se lever au petit matin, aller travailler, revenir à la maison, regarder la télé, aller se coucher,
faire la fête le weekend.
Beaucoup de gens affirment, "Je vis." Non, tu ne vis pas -- tu ne fais qu'exister.
Rien qu'exister.
Je pense vraiment qu'il existe un désir inné.
Je crois vraiment ce que Chris affirme. Je crois que vous n'êtes pas un accident.
Vos parents ne vous ont peut être pas planifié, mais j'estime que Dieu lui l'a fait.
J'imagine que des gens se retrouvent parents par accident, cela ne fait aucun doute.
Je ne pense pas qu'il existe d'enfants nés par accident.
Et je pense que vous avez de l'importance.
Je pense que vous êtes important aux yeux de Dieu, je pense que vous êtes important aux yeux de l'histoire,
je pense que vous êtes important aux yeux de l'univers.
Et je pense que la différence entre
ce que j'appelle la vie à un niveau de survie, la vie à un niveau de réussite
et la vie à un niveau d'importance est,
arrivez-vous à comprendre pourquoi êtes-vous sur Terre?
Je rencontre de nombreuses personnes qui sont très intelligentes,
et qui disent, "Mais pourquoi ne puis-je pas résoudre mes problèmes?"
Et je rencontre beaucoup de personnes qui réussisent très bien,
qui disent, "Pourquoi je ne me sens pas plus comblé?
Pourquoi ai-je l'impression d'être un imposteur?
Pourquoi ai-je l'impression
de devoir prétendre être plus que ce que je suis?"
Je pense que tout cela se ramène au problème du sens, de l'importance, du but.
Je pense que cela se ramène au problème du
pourquoi suis-je ici? Que suis-je censé faire? où vais-je?
Ce ne sont pas des questions religieuses --
ce sont des questions humaines.
Je voulais dire à Michael avant qu'il ne prenne la parole
que j’apprécie vraiment ce qu'il fait,
car cela rend mon travail beaucoup plus facile.
En tant que pasteur, je rencontre beaucoup d'excentriques.
Et j'ai appris qu'il existe des excentriques dans tous les domaines de la vie.
La religion n'a pas
le monopole à cet égard, néanmoins il existe de nombreux fous religieux.
Il y a des fous laïques, il y a des fous intelligents, des fous idiots.
Il y a des gens -- une femme est venu me voir l'autre jour,
et elle avait une feuille de papier blanc -- Michael, tu vas l'aimer celle là --
et elle a dit, "Qu'est ce que vous voyez là-dedans?"
Alors j'ai regardé et j'ai dit, "Oh, je ne vois rien du tout."
et alors elle réplique, "Et bien, je vois Jesus,", commence à pleurer et s'en va.
Je pensais, d'accord.
Hum.
Félicitations.
Lorsque le bouquin est devenu le livre le plus vendu au monde ces trois dernières années,
J'ai eu une sorte de crise.
Qui était, quel est le but de cela?
Parce que, ça me rapportait une énorme somme d'argent.
Quand vous écrivez le livre le plus vendu au monde,
ça veut dire des masses d'argent.
Et cela m'a apporté beaucoup d'attention, même si je ne voulais ni de l'un, ni de l'autre.
Quand j'ai fondé l'église Saddleback, j'avais 25 ans.
Je l'ai fondée avec une autre famille en 1980.
Et j'ai décidé de ne jamais passer à la télé,
parce que je ne voulais pas devenir une célébrité,
je ne voulais pas être, je cite, " un évangéliste, un télévangéliste" --
ce n'est pas mon truc.
Et tout d'un coup, ça m'a rapporté beaucoup d'argent et d'attention.
Je ne crois pas --
alors, ceci est une vision du monde, et je vais vous dire, tout le monde a sa vision du monde.
Tout le monde mise sa vie sur quelque chose.
Vous misez votre vie sur quelque chose --
vous avez intérêt d'être bien sûr de la raison pour laquelle vous misez là-dessus.
Alors, tout le monde mise sa vie sur quelque chose,
et pour ma part, vous savez, quand j'ai misé, il se trouvait que je croyais
que Jésus était celui qu'il avait dit qu'il était.
Mais tout le monde a -- et je crois dans une société pluraliste --
tout le monde mise sur quelque chose.
Et lorsque j'ai lançé l'église,
voyez, je n'avais pas prévu de faire ce qu'elle fait aujourd'hui.
Et alors quand j'ai écrit ce livre,
tout d'un coup, ça a tout simplement
décollé,
et alors j'ai commencé à me demander, maintenant, quel est le but de cela?
Parce que comme je disais,
je pense que vous n'obtenez jamais de l'argent ou de la gloire
pour votre amour-propre.
Je n'y crois pas tout simplement.
Et quand vous écrivez un livre dont la première phrase est,
"Cela n'a rien à voir avec vous,"
alors, quand tout d'un coup
cela devient le livre le plus vendu de l'histoire,
il faut se dire, et bien, je suppose que ça n'a rien à voir avec moi.
Cela va de soi.
Alors, à quoi ça sert?
Et j'ai commencé à penser à ce que j'appelle l'intendance de la richesse
et l'intendance de l'influence.
Alors je crois, qu'en gros, diriger revient à faire de l'intendance.
Que si vous êtes un leader dans n'importe quel domaine --
dans les affaires, la politique, le sport, l'art,
l'éducation, dans n'importe quel domaine --
cela ne vous appartient pas,
vous en êtes seulement l'intendant.
Par exemple, c'est pour cela que je crois en la défense de l'environnement.
Ce n'est pas ma planète. Ce n'était pas ma propriété avant que je naisse.
Et ce ne sera pas non plus la mienne après ma mort.
Je suis juste ici pour 80 ans et puis c'est tout.
Je débattais l'autre jour sur un plateau télé,
et l'autre personne me provoquait, il disait,
"Qu'est-ce que fait un pasteur à protéger l'environnement?"
Et j'ai demandé à cette personne, j'ai dit, " Et bien, croyez-vous
que les humains ont la responsabilité
de faire du monde un meilleur endroit pour vivre pour les prochaines générations?
Pensez-vous que nous avons un rôle d'intendance dans cette situation,
qui nous pousserait à prendre l'environnement au sérieux?
Et il m'a répondu, "Non."
J'ai dit, "Vraiment, vous ne pensez pas?" j'ai dit, "Laissez moi vous expliquer plus clairement.
Croyez-vous qu'en tant qu'humains -- et je ne parle pas de religion --
croyez-vous qu'en tant qu'êtres humains, c'est notre responsabilité
de prendre soin de cette planète et de la rendre un petit peu plus confortable pour les générations futures?"
Et il a répondu, "Non.
Pas plus que les autres espèces."
Quand il a prononcé le mot "espèce", il a révélé sa vision du monde.
Et il expliquait, "Prendre soin de l'environnement n'est pas plus ma responsabilité
que celle d'un canard."
Et bien, je sais que bien souvent nous agissons comme des canards,
mais vous n'en êtes pas un.
Vous n'êtes pas un canard.
Et vous êtes responsable -- c'est ma vision du monde.
Et alors, vous devez comprendre ce qu'est votre monde, ce qu'est la vision du monde.
Le soucis est que la plupart des gens ne parviennent pas à faire le tour du problème.
Ils ne le codifient,
le qualifient ou le quantifient jamais vraiment,
pour arriver à dire, "Voilà ce en quoi je crois.
Voilà pourquoi je crois en cela."
Personnellement, je ne pense pas avoir assez de foi pour être athée.
Mais vous pouvez, vous pouvez.
Votre vision du monde, néanmoins, détermine vraiment tout le reste dans votre vie,
parce qu'elle détermine vos décisions,
elle détermine vos relations,
elle détermine votre niveau de confiance.
elle détermine, vraiment, tout dans votre vie.
Ce que nous croyons, manifestement --
et vous savez cela -- elle détermine notre comportement,
et notre comportement détermine ce que l'on devient dans la vie.
Alors tout cet argent a commencé à couler à flots,
et toute cette gloire a afflué,
et je pense, qu'est-ce que je fais avec ça?
Ma femme et moi avont initialement pris cinq décisions concernant l'usage de cet argent.
Nous avons dit, "Premièrement,
nous n'allons pas le dépenser pour nous."
Je ne suis pas aller acheter une maison plus grande.
Je ne suis pas le propriétaire d'une maison d'hôtes.
Je continue de conduire la même Ford vieille de quatre ans que je conduisais auparavant.
Nous avons juste dit, nous n'allons pas le dépenser pour nous.
La deuxième chose était,
que j'ai arrêté de percevoir mon salaire de pasteur au sein de l'église.
La troisième chose, j'ai calculé tout ce que l'église m'avait donné durant les 25 dernières années,
et je l'ai redonné.
Et je l'ai donné parce que je ne voulais pas que les gens pensent
que je fais ça pour l'argent -- ce n'est pas le cas.
En fait, personnellement, je n'ai jamais rencontré
de prètre, pasteur ou ministre de culte qui le faisait pour de l'argent.
Je sais que c'est un stéréotype. Je n'en ai jamais rencontré.
Croyez-moi, il existe une multitude de façons plus simples de gagner de l'argent.
Les pasteurs doivent être disponibles 24 heures sur 24. Comme des médecins.
Je suis parti tard aujourd'hui. J'aurais aimé être ici hier,
parce que mon beau père est en train de vivre, probablement, ses dernières 48 heures
avant de mourir d'un cancer.
Et je me retrouve à regarder un homme qui a vécu sa vie --
il a maintenant 85 ans --
et il meurt en paix. Vous savez, la mise à l'épreuve de votre vision du monde
ne se fait pas quand tout va bien.
La mise à l'épreuve de votre vision du monde se passe quand vous participez à un enterrement.
Et pour avoir participé littéralement à des centaines si ce n'est des milliers d'enterrements,
ça fait une différence.
Les choses en quoi vous croyez font une différence.
Alors, nous avons tout redonné,
et après, nous avons mis en place ces trois fondations,
pour travailler sur les principaux problèmes au monde:
l'analphabétisme, la pauvreté, les pandémies -- particulièrement le VIH/le Sida --
et nous avons en place ces fondations,
et les avons financées avec cet argent.
La dernière chose que nous avons faite est que nous sommes devenus ce que j'appelle des "redonneurs de dîmes."
Et ça c'était, quand ma femme et moi nous sommes mariés
il y a 30 ans,
on a commencé à reverser cette dîme.
Et, c'est un principe dans la Bible
qui dit de donner 10 pour cent de ce que l'on gagne à la charité,
le donner pour aider d'autres gens.
Donc, on a commencé à faire cela, et chaque année, on mettait de côté notre dîme de 10 pour cent.
Alors, pour notre première année de mariage, on est allé jusqu'à 11 pour cent,
la deuxième année, on est monté à 12 pour cent,
et la troisième année, on est allé juqu'à 13 pour cent,
etc. Pourquoi ais-je fait cela?
Parce que à chaque fois que je donne,
ça relâche l'emprise du matérialisme sur ma vie.
Le matérialisme revient à posséder -- posséder, posséder, posséder, posséder tout ce qu'on peut,
garder ce qu'on possède, s'asseoir sur le butin et se gâter.
Tout est question de supplément, d'avoir plus.
Et nous pensons que la belle vie est en fait avoir une belle apparence.
C'est ce qui a le plus d'importance -- avoir une belle apparence,
se sentir bien et posséder les biens.
Mais ce n'est pas ça la belle vie.
Je rencontre constamment des gens qui possèdent tout cela,
et ils ne sont pas forcément heureux.
Si l'argent rendait vraiment heureux,
alors les personnes les plus fortunées seraient les plus heureuses.
Et ça, je sais personnellement, que ce n'est pas vrai.
Ce n'est tout simplement pas vrai.
Alors, la belle vie ne se résume pas à avoir une belle apparence, se sentir bien ou posséder les biens.
mais plutôt à être bon et à faire le bien.
Donner de nos vies.
L'importance dans la vie ne vient pas du statut,
parce que vous pouvez toujours trouver quelqu'un qui a plus que vous.
Cela ne vient pas du sexe.
Cela ne vient pas du salaire.
Cela vient du fait de servir.
C'est en donnant de nos vies que nous trouvons un sens,
que nous trouvons de l'importance.
C'est de cette façon que nous avons été programmés, je crois, par Dieu.
Et alors nous avons commencé à donner de nos vies,
et aujourd'hui, 30 ans plus tard,
ma femme et moi sommes toujours des verseurs de dîmes -- nous reversons 90 pour cent et vivons avec les 10 pour cent restants.
Ceci, en fait, était la partie facile.
La partie difficile était, qu'est-ce que je fais de toute cette attention?
Parce que j'ai commencé à recevoir toutes sortes d'invitations.
Je viens juste de terminer un cercle de conférence long de presque un mois
sur trois continents différents,
et je ne parlerai pas de cela,
mais c'était quelque chose d'incroyable.
Et je me dis, qu'est-ce que je fais avec cela,
avec toute cette notoriété que le livre a apporté?
Et étant un pasteur, j'ai commencé à lire la Bible.
Il existe un chapître dans la Bible appelé Psaume 72,
et c'est la prière de Salomon pour plus d'influence.
Quand vous lisez cette prière,
ça sonne incroyablement égoïste et égocentrique.
On dirait,
qu'il dit, "Dieu, je veux que tu me rendes celèbre."
Voilà ce qu'il prie.
Il dit, "je veux que tu me rendes célèbre.
Je veux que tu rendes mon nom célèbre à travers tous les continents,
je veux que tu me donnes le pouvoir,
je veux que tu me rendes célèbre.
je veux que tu me donne de l'influence."
Et cela semble être la demande la plus égoïste possible et imaginable
si vous allez prier.
A moins de lire l'intégralité du psaume, le chapitre entier.
Et alors il dit, "Pour que le roi" --
il était roi d'Israel à l'époque, au sommet de son pouvoir --
"pour que le roi puisse prendre soin de la veuve et de l'orphelin,
puisse s'occuper du déprimé, puisse défendre les sans-défenses, puisse prendre soin des malades,
puisse venir en aide au pauvre, puisse prendre la parole pour l'étranger,
pour ceux en prison."
Fondamentalement, il englobe tous les marginaux de la société.
Et quand j'ai lu cela,
j'ai regardé, et j'ai pensé, vous savez,
ce que cela nous dit est que le but de l'influence est de prendre la parole
pour ceux qui n'en n'ont pas.
Le but de l'influence n'est pas de renforcer votre amour-propre,
ou votre valeur nette.
Et, soit dit en passant, votre valeur nette n'est pas le même chose
que votre amour-propre.
Votre valeur n'est pas basée sur vos objets de valeur,
elle est basée sur un ensemble de chose bien différentes.
Et donc le but de l'influence est de prendre la parole
pour ceux qui n'ont pas d'influence.
Et j'ai dû admettre,
je ne peux pas me souvenir de la dernière fois que j'ai pensé aux veuves et aux orphelins.
Je ne fais pas attention à eux.
Je suis pasteur d'une église dans l'une des zones les plus riches d'Amérique --
une poignée d'ensembles résidentiesl protégés.
Mon église est pleine à craquer de PDG et de savants.
Et je pourrais faire cela pendant cinq ans sans voir l'ombre d'un sans-abri.
Ils ne sont tout simplement pas sur mon chemin.
Et ils se trouvent à Santa Ana, 20 kilomètres en suivant la route.
Alors il a fallu que je dise, "OK,
j'utiliserai toute la richesse et l'influence que j'ai
pour aider ceux qui n'ont aucune des deux."
Vous savez, il y a une histoire dans la Bible sur Moïse.
Que vous pensiez que ça soit vrai ou pas --
cela n'a pas vraiment d'importance pour moi.
Mais Moïse, si vous avez vu le film, "Les dix commandements,"
Moïse se promène, et il y a ce buisson ardent, et Dieu s'adresse à lui.
Et Dieu dit, "Moïse,
qu'est-ce qu'il y a dans ta main?"
Je pense que c'est la question la plus importante qu'on puisse vous demander.
Qu'est-ce qu'il y a dans ta main?
Moïse dit, "C'est un bâton.
C'est un bâton de berger."
Et Dieu lui dit, "Jette-le par terre."
Et si vous avez vu le film, vous savez, il le jette et il se transforme en serpent.
Et alors Dieu dit, "Ramasse-le."
Et il le ramasse,
et il se retransforme en bâton.
Maintenant, je suis en train de lire ça, et je me dis, pourquoi tout cela?
OK. Pourquoi tout cela? Et bien, il y a bien deux ou trois trucs que je sais.
Premièrement, Dieu ne fait jamais de miracles pour faire le fier.
Ce n'est pas seulement, "Wow, c'est pas cool ça?"
Et, soit dit en passant, mon Dieu n'apparaît pas sur des tartines de fromage.
Je veux dire, si Dieu doit se montrer,
il ne va pas le faire sur une tartine de fromage.
(Rires)
OK? je vais juste, c'est pour ça que j'aime ce que fait Michael,
parce que c'est comme, OK, si il est train de le démystifier, alors je n'ai pas à le faire.
Mais Dieu -- mon Dieu -- ne se voit pas sur des images d'arroseur.
Il dispose de méthodes bien plus puissantes que celle-ci
pour arriver à ses fins.
Mais il ne réalise pas de miracles juste pour faire le fier.
La deuxième chose est, que si il arrivait que Dieu vous pose une question,
il connait déjà la réponse.
Evidemment, si c'est Dieu alors cela signifie
que quand il pose une question, c'est pour votre bénéfice, pas pour le Sien.
Alors, il demande, "Qu'y a-t-il dans ta main?"
Alors, qu'est-ce Moïse a dans la main?
Et bien, c'est un bâton de berger. Alors, suivez-moi bien.
Ce bâton représente trois choses qui concernent la vie de Moïse.
Premièrement, il représente son identité.
Il était berger. C'est le symbole de sa propre profession.
Je suis berger. C'est un symbole de son identité, sa carrière, son métier.
Deuxièmement, ce n'est pas seulement un symbole de son identité,
c'est un symbole de son revenu, parce que tous ses biens sont liés aux moutons.
A l'époque, personne n'avait de compte bancaire,
de carte American Express ou bien de fonds de couverture.
Vos biens sont réunis dans votre troupeau.
Donc c'est un symbole de son identité, et c'est un symbole de son revenu.
Et la troisième chose: c'est un symbole de son influence.
Que faites-vous avec un bâton de berger?
Et bien, vous savez, vous emmenez les moutons d'un point A à un point B,
par tous les moyens.
Vous les tirez ou vous les poussez à coups de bâton,tantôt l'un tantôt l'autre.
Alors, il dit,
"tu vas poser par terre ton identité.
Qu'y a-t-il dans ta main? Tu as une identité, tu as un revenu, tu as de l'influence.
Qu'y a-t-il dans ta main?"
Et il dit, "Si tu le poses par terre, je le ferai prendre vie.
Je ferai des choses que tu n'aurais jamais pu imaginer possibles."
Et si vous avez vu ce film, "Les dix commandements,"
tous ces grands miracles qui se produisent en Egypte
sont réalisés avec ce bâton.
L'année dernière, j'ai été invité pour parler à l'occasion d'un match de la NBA All-Stars.
Et donc, je suis en train de parler aux joueurs,
parce que la plupart des équipes de NBA, des équipes de NFL et de toutes les autres équipes
ont fait ces 40 Days of Purpose, comme dans le livre.
Et je leur ai demandé, j'ai dit, "Qu' y a-t-il dans votre main?
Alors, qu'y a-t-il dans votre main?" j'ai dit, "c'est un ballon de basket,
et ce ballon de basket représente votre identité, qui vous êtes.
Vous êtes des joueurs de NBA. Il représente votre revenu.
Vous gagnez beaucoup d'argent grâce à cette petite balle.
Et elle représente votre influence.
Et même si vous n'allez rester dans la NBA que quelques années,
vous resterez des joueurs de NBA toute votre vie.
Et cela vous confère une énorme influence.
Alors, qu'allez-vous faire de tout ce que vous avez reçu?"
Et je suppose que c'est la raison principale pour laquelle je suis venu ici aujourd'hui,
parmi vous, brillants auditeurs de TED,
je viens vous dire, "Qu'y a-t-il dans votre main?"
Qu'avez-vous que l'on vous a donné?
Talent, formation, éducation,
liberté, réseaux, opportunités,
richesse, idées, créativité.
Qu'allez-vous faire
de ce qu'on vous a donné?
Ceci est pour moi, la question première de la vie.
Ceci est pour moi, ce qu'est réellement d'être motivé par un objectif.
Dans le livre, j'explique comment vous êtes prédestiné à faire certaines choses, vous êtes configuré.
Cette petite croix se nourrit de cadeaux spirituels, de coeur,
d'aptitude, de personnalité et d'expériences.
Ces choses vous façonnent.
Et si vous voulez savoir ce que vous devez faire de votre vie,
vous devez regarder quelle forme vous avez. Pourquoi ai-je été conçu?
Pourquoi est-ce que Dieu me prédestinerait à faire quelque chose
pour ne pas le faire par la suite?
Si vous êtes destiné à être anthropologue, vous serez anthropologue.
Si vous êtes destiné à explorer les fonds marins,
vous serez amené à explorer les fonds marins.
Si vous êtes destiné à faire des affaires, vous ferez des affaires.
Si vous êtes destiné à la peinture, vous deviendrez peintre.
Saviez-vous que Dieu sourit quand vous êtes vous-même?
Quand mes enfants étaient petits --
ils sont grands maintenant, j'ai même des petits enfants --
j'avais l'habitude de m'asseoir sur le bord du lit,
et de regarder mes enfants dormir.
Et je regardais leurs petits corps monter et descendre,
monter et descendre.
Et je les regardais, ceci n'est pas un accident.
Monter et descendre.
Et le simple fait de les regarder dormir me remplissait de joie.
Certaines personnes ont l'idée fausse que Dieu ne s'emballe
que lorsque vous faites, et je cite, des "choses spirituelles",
comme aller à l'église ou aider les pauvres,
ou, vous savez, se confesser ou des choses comme ça.
Pour aller à l'essentiel, Dieu se plait à vous regarder être vous-même. Pourquoi cela?
Il vous a créé. Et lorsque vous faites ce que vous étiez destiné faire,
Il se dit, "ça c'est mon fils.
Ca c'est ma fille.
Tu utilises le talent et l'aptitude que je t'ai donné."
Alors mon conseil est le suivant,
regardez ce qu'il y a dans votre main --
votre identité, votre influence, votre revenu --
et dites, "Il ne s'agit pas de moi.
C'est de faire de ce monde un meilleur endroit pour vivre."
Merci.